[Music]
hey there look this doesn't look like a
regular matinee show we're gonna do a
little bit different this time yeah now
in case you didn't like I post it on
Facebook and I post on our blog and on
the patreon page for the public and
everything like that
but what we decided to do because we
have some situations I mean we still
have the a-list program and we're still
gonna go to the theater and see stuff
when stuff is playing but we had a
situation this week where really nothing
new came out except Lion King and I'm
like man I do not want to see Lion King
I give a [ __ ] about life well and not
only that happening we're not saying
good things about it not only that
happening but also my car went tits up
meaning that every time we want to go
someplace now we have to borrow someone
else's car which is kind of a pain in
the ass you got motorcycles but I sold
my car off yes motorcycle and here's the
deal is is that Jenny's there come the
AC compressor went out yeah okay and the
a/c compressors which means man I'm
gonna have to get in there
the compressor sells about 200 but
cleaning out all that damn all the lines
it's got you know it's it's rough to do
that from from home because you gotta
get that whole system clean then you
install that compressor and make sure
the clutch is running right and then
chances are it's gonna burn out in a
couple years anyway and then we're
investing in a car that has over a
hundred eighty thousand miles on it yeah
okay it's time for a new car so I chose
the 2004 u.s. yeah so I'm not living the
highlife over here so my kids good I'm
just gonna buy another car and over the
next couple months I was gonna save up
for a decent sized down payment yeah I
mean we've got a car in Jenny Jenny
split it with me yeah we have a relative
who's you know long car whose car we can
borrow if we need to but like I said if
there's nothing new playing at the
theater you know we don't necessarily
want to go have to see stuff twice just
to get three movies and you know like I
said now that it's a bigger pain in the
ass because we don't have ready access
to a car and I got the idea it's like
well you know a bunch of new movies
don't even play in the theaters they
either you know bypass the theater or
just make the festival certainly much
goodness
like [ __ ] anyway yeah either they come
straight out to VOD like Netflix picks
them up Horrocks got a lot of good stuff
yeah we can rent them from Xbox or you
know so what I said we could do is if we
need to fill out stuff from the theater
it's like we'll just pick my only you
know limitation being that it had to
come out this year like the current year
so these are all movies from 2019 and I
will specify like where you can see them
like on what streaming service you can
see them most of them can also be rented
through your Xbox Amazon primal Dawkins
funny thing was is that we we actually
decided to do that AMC thing so we could
get out of the house because we we
really don't ever really have to leave
the house yeah I mean we we work from
home yeah this is my this is my work
yeah my office and we order everything
pretty much we buy we have to go grocery
shop and maybe once a month oh yeah and
we were going to the club once a month
so yeah really enough didn't need the
car yeah you know that much but we're
gonna get a car because we do have to go
to the club yeah shop and stuff like
that so yeah it is a pain not having yes
but I want giving them [ __ ] Cadillacs
yeah I'm gonna get an old man car here
50 man I deserved a Cadillac
we'll see we'll see what I said the same
yeah man give me a [ __ ] big old
American Cadillac course wind of course
when he was buying Cadillacs they were
as big as a [ __ ] plane yeah the new
ones now are awesome they're awesome
okay I probably get one as couple years
old yeah well yeah I can't afford it
yeah especially not a new Cadillac for
chrissake yeah so like I said what we
decided to do was we're just going to go
through and find movies that came out on
Netflix or that are to rent on Amazon
Prime or Xbox or that came out exclusive
to shutter but as long as they came out
this year they're fair game
and I thought this would be kind of cool
because maybe we can like turn people on
to some movies that you know we thought
were good that maybe you wouldn't have
thought of watching or that kind of went
under the radar or something like that
so pretty much all of the movies this
week are going to be that so we're gonna
be doing them all from home so the first
one we are going to be talking about is
a little 2019 film that is on Netflix
currently called rim of the world I was
pleasantly surprised by this one I was
also like I had
you know scoured through a couple of
lists like looking it's like you know
what some good horror and sci-fi that
came out this year whether in the
theater whether right to be OD or
whatever and this came up on a couple of
lists and I noticed that it was on
Netflix so we decided to watch it last
evening and it was super [ __ ] fun
yeah I thought it was a blast yeah I
mean you could just sound discs in a
theatrical I do not believe that it did
alright um it was directed by McGee who
is actually he's a music producer and
stuff like that he also did the
Charlie's Angels movie the one with Drew
Barrymore maybe all of them but I'm
pretty sure he just did the first one
but he wanted to oh yeah I don't think
that this actually ever got a theatrical
release
fun fact though this movie was actually
the week that it came out on Netflix it
was the highest watched movie in the UK
it was their number one if this got a
theatrical release it probably would
have done pretty well if it had if it
had decent hype I kind of feel like - I
mean especially behaved oh yeah yeah I
mean this is definitely what this is
it's basically a sci-fi comedy adventure
very much in the line of you need your
80s kind of like kids action adventure
sci fi a lien J's world type of thing
yeah and there's like a lot of like
really direct homage --is it's rather
like stranger things in that regard
except like maybe a little more over the
top straight stuff straight out of
Jurassic park's oh yeah there's one
sequence it's exactly like straight out
Independence Day et et predator writer
Danny's yang
yeah gladiator like this club they made
a very funny yeah and the overall tone
is basically Spielberg it is very
Spielberg it's good I liked it yeah
enjoyed it it was kind of like one of
those comforting movies that kind of
even though it's not old it kind of it
kind of has a nostalgic feel to it yeah
even like it even had like those that
big epic like orchestral orchestral
score like this be oberg movies used to
have and it kind of has that tone like I
said it's a little likable characters
yeah really good humor
old-school humor like you don't really
see because good humor is actually kind
of inappropriate right now if you want
to listen to somebody's Hollywood you
know media types oh that's you know it's
terrible
so it's plenty of not plenty of
politically incorrect humor that's still
[ __ ] funny um I have to say my
favorite yoke and it was a joke about
Verner Hertzog's Grizzly Man yeah I was
not expecting that and it just like
cracked me the hell up
yeah but basically what this movie is
about and like I said these movies are
new and this is on Netflix if you want
to watch it you still can so I'm not
gonna spoil anything but I will give you
just a very like you know bare minimum
like what the plots about this is
basically about four kids they're about
13 years old and they're kind of all
different social types like I said there
was kind of like a little of every
blatant like a Breakfast Club shout out
and you know there's one there's a
Chinese girl named Jen Jen who's kind of
like mysterious like she doesn't talk
from her side punk rocker though and
dresses kind of like a rocker like in a
Boy Scout uniform she yeah she's super
badass there's a guy there's a kid named
Alex who's like a redheaded freckled
ginger kid he was like super afraid of
everything and is like you know real
nerdy and like science nerdy yeah this
element of it kind of reminded me of
remember that was it was called a
Christmas story maybe the one where your
eye out and yeah yeah yeah all the kids
there's a lot of that kind of tone yeah
between this cast but you could also
price at Goonies too well yeah I got a
goonie yeah and especially like the
whole you know all these like diverse
kids like banding together like a save
literally save the world in this case
then there's also like kind of a chubby
black kid named Darius who actually
comes from like a super super wealthy
family like it's not like his dad's like
didn't they say like he owned a car
dealership or something I don't remember
what it was but he lived in this big
mansion and he had like an Indian man
surf vendors oh yeah there was all that
guys and then there was like this kind
of mysterious like slightly older kid
that they meet later on and you don't
really know what his deal is until later
yeah and basically they're all out at
this camp called the rim of the world in
California and they all kind of get
separated from the rest of the group and
while they're separated there is a huge
alien attack yeah he started off with
EMPs
yeah aerial fights between f30
and you know Raptors and spaceships and
very independence day a kind of
situation going funnier but funnier tone
is spot on actually I thought it was
hilarious because kinda like predator
and the thing in Friday the 13th all at
the same time because they're running
from a damn alien monster inside of a
inside of a camp yeah I like the
settings like a slasher I guess like
like like Friday the 13th kana
but there's humor you know and it's just
funny it's just it's good yeah like I
said I really liked it very much
you know and the kids like I said it's
basically just an adventure movie is it
the aliens attack all the adults get
some of them get killed some of them get
vanished yet manage they're taking away
and whatever so these kids like you know
they are basically have to get to the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory and deliver
this thing that's supposedly gonna stop
the whole family and then it becomes
like a survival movie and it's partially
a damn Fast and Furious movie mixed with
Mad Max it's it's pretty cool yeah I
mean like I said get a Mach 3 Mustang
and jumps on top of it the Chinese girls
driving it she's like maybe 11 below
they're supposed to around 13 but some
of them might be older yo they're like
twins yeah okay okay so she's all over
that thought she was yeah you know it
was just it was good man yeah yeah it
was an action yes super super fun like I
said if you like like kind of throwback
80s omage movies you know if you like
stranger things if you liked you know
the Goonies if in Jurassic Park not
stuff like that it's very much in that
man I could tell that this movie was
probably made on the back of the success
of that first and second season a
stranger oh yeah definitely definitely
because they knew that there was like
you know a big audience for this
particularly on Netflix yeah if you like
stranger things you'll love this yeah I
feel like you won't like I said it's
more over the top there's a lot more
it's a lot funnier like it's a lot
broader than stranger things but it's in
a similar vein yeah and it's only it's
only a movies maybe two hours long so
it's all very self-contained and compact
yeah story you know I mean it's not it's
not a whole series like stranger things
so it gets it's it gets the job done
over with
quick yeah it tells a story and that's
it can I say it ends up kind of being
like reminded me a lot of Independence
Day when they were finally beaten the
aliens in a way in the government in the
military were involved in a lot control
rooms and yeah kind of reminded me that
can I say I also loved the sequence
where it had that really really like a
lot of 80s movies had that with that
really brightly with like nighttime like
that bright neon lighting is a bright
pink and like bright blue and bright and
green and it's like it looked really
cool there was like a whole like
nighttime sequence that Toback colors
yeah so it was really cool so like I
said if you like that kind of 80s
throwback like action sci-fi adventure
kids comedy like know this and none of
the kids are annoying all the kids were
super likable you will probably love
this it's on Netflix I don't think it's
anywhere else I'm sure you maybe can
rent it and stuff like that maybe the
Hollywood blockbuster a run for its
money yeah like I said I thought it was
the Oh fun I just I laughed my ass off
yeah the whole thing and I was and I was
totally invested in the characters I'm
like go kids go you know what I mean and
I like us the effects were great and was
good everything about the movie was
top-notch yeah so great movie definitely
recommend it
you
all right so the second movie we're
gonna talk about our matinee show was
the 2019 film I am mother I liked it I
did as well now this actually premiered
at the Sundance Film Festival in January
of this year and it actually came out on
Netflix in June now this one
it did get or is getting a theatrical
release but only in Australia it's
starting in July 18th why it's not
getting a theatrical release here I
don't really know movie was spot on man
I liked it it was very very good and
this was actually the the director of
this and I'm not sure how to pronounce
his last name but his name is a grants
puto boo Tori something like that this
is actually his first film damn this is
yeah good going right this is also a
sci-fi movie but much out in a much more
serious much more serious tone yeah kind
of believable yeah this actually kind of
reminded me it reminded me a lot of moon
with Sam Rockwell yeah which I loved
yeah has a kind of a similar prep
similar premise to 10 Cloverfield Lane
if you saw that with the whole bunker
thing and like you know telling somebody
telling somebody that there can't go out
and stuff so it has kind of a similar
thing to that well yeah if you play
fallout it's happening in a bunker kind
of like a fallout type bunker but it's
AI it's run by a damn robot yeah got a
seed bank of all these unborn children
in it and it it brought to life one girl
has raising it as her daughter this
robot is yeah and it's badass I mean the
the movie looks really good yeah it is
it look beautiful being a ride it looks
at it looks real the robot looks real
everything in it looks real it's Connor
it had a vibe kind of like in some ways
kind of like 2001 a Space Odyssey with
how running the damned
yeah kind of like halibut it's female
and it kind of looks like the Terminator
with Terminator type robots in a
terminator type situation an end of the
world and a downfall of mankind type
deal eventually she does get out you
don't know what's going on you don't
know if
a Mad Max world out there is it poison
because it supposed to be like a lethal
bioweapon type problem or a plague out
there but that's the story unfold you
find out there's a lot more to this that
it first meets the eye the acting was
really good special effects super good
yeah it's like super yeah I mean Hillary
Swank was in this um the the girl that's
in it like I said now the the robot
mother that's actually a person in there
that's a male stunt performer and then
it's an actress Rose Byrne who does the
voice yeah and like you said you know
the girl that's in it I think her name
is Clara rugaard
and she is raised she's never given a
name she's just called daughter and she
is raised from an embryo by this robot
like an AI robot in this bunker now for
her entire life you see her kind of you
know as a baby for a few minutes and
then like as a toddler and like you kind
of see a little bit of the bonding ya
know they're gonna be spoilers coming up
no no I'm just giving like a scene this
damn movie you should go see it yeah you
know because we don't want to spoil it
yeah but the best thing about the movie
is that the whole thing it's like it
pretty much almost the entire thing
takes place in one location and it's
just two characters most of the time
yeah but the thing about it it's like it
keeps you on the edge of your seat the
whole time because you're not entirely
sure and especially like when someone
else like comes into the mix you're not
sure entirely who to trust like you know
who's telling the truth who's lying you
know what's really going on yeah the
daughter starts to suspect that the
robot lies ya know is that it's lying
about the situation outside it's lying
about what its plans are for all these
embryos and it takes a while for it to
all kind of unfold and I have to say I
didn't really see where it was going
like I think I think I kind of like
thought it was gonna go a different way
yeah so I'm actually glad that it sort
of surprised me because I thought oh
maybe this that and the other thing but
that's not how it turned out alright but
um yeah so I would definitely recommend
this movie if you specially if you liked
moon if you liked any it's you know it's
very it's kind of like a
like I said kind of like 10 Cloverfield
Lane similar type of things the look of
the movies spot-on yeah look at the
movie is kind of like aliens too you
know
yeah and something out of one of the
Terminator movies yeah it kind of has
looks like you're in the middle like the
Cyberdyne corporation or something where
they make the Terminator robot see you
know it's just there's more to it you'll
see what I'm talking about when as the
movie unfolds I don't want to spoil
anything and like I said this is
definitely one where I mean you know the
last movie we talked about room in the
world it's like that's not such a huge
deal if you spoil stuff because it's
just like a comedy it's a comedy it's an
adventure movie but this one so much of
what makes the movie good is not only
two acting performances but also like
the fact that you never know entirely
sure what's going on so you always have
to like you know pay attention and see
you like yes what's gonna happen who's
telling the truth and he's not certain
things aren't really given to you it's
just kind of implied yeah exactly
actually how it is yeah you just gotta
see it for yourself Adam I have a theory
about the ending but oh yeah of course
I'm not gonna so if anybody seen it I
want to say like in the company is put
spoiler on it and it doesn't really have
a downer ending I mean it's just it's
the ending makes sense
once it's over yeah you just find out
what to did what the installation was is
for you know just I can't spoil it yeah
that's all I'm saying I want to say to
you that this movie has actually been
because I guess the screenplay has been
floating around for a few years and in
2016 it was on you know the very famous
screenplay blacklist which is they put
out a list every year of like the most
liked screenplays like you know by
screenwriters by Hollywood producers by
whoever so this has been going around
for a long time and a lot of studios
wanted it so they eventually got around
to making it yeah so it's been on the
black list for three years and they
finally got around to making it like I
said this is getting a theatrical
release in Australia but here we're
getting it on this movie this movie
could have almost been a Kubrick flick
and that's then that's a that's you know
it did have kind of a Kubrick Ian yeah
if could if Kubrick
had a sci-fi
fun side too well I won't call it fun
but um yeah it's not it's not imagine
Rick wanted to kind of make something
out of aliens and Prometheus and maybe
something kind of like what was that Tom
Cruise flick that I kind of compared
Elysium service car oblivion oblivion
yeah oh yeah it is kind of what I love
the movie oblivion oh yeah oh it's
similar to that to the similar tongue
yeah I like oblivion or like sunshine
Danny Boyle movie or Solaris it has a
little bit of that you all right oh it
is I I really respect the movie I think
it's very good I really do I'm not very
good
I guess you said kind of had a Kubrick
Ian's attention to detail a little bit
depth to it yeah you know I mean it's
like some Kubrick would have been
interested in yeah yeah and I mean
apparently we're not the only one saying
that cuz I actually checked what it's
Rotten Tomatoes score was 91%
yes ative no reviews so pretty much
across the board so I definitely
definitely recommend this movie it's
like really good and I was just like
riveted the whole entire time like to
see what was going on but these just the
mothers Olga kind of reminded me of the
Hal 9000 I mean that's why I'm kind of
saying yeah like I said it gave me so
much of like a moon type of vibe yeah
where Sam Rockwell is like at this moon
base know himself and all this other
kind of stuff so yeah it's not that
situation though no Nia yeah it's not
like that but it it gave me that sort of
like a feeling right like something
wasn't quite right with the situation
and you know she don't know exactly what
and you have to like yeah it's fine oh I
know what it is but yeah so this is
definitely definitely a good movie
definitely if you love sci-fi go and
check it out yeah I'm gonna put this up
there with Prometheus and aliens and
[ __ ] yeah that Tom Cruise movie that I
just forgot yeah like that like that
yeah if your sigh 5,000 watch you're a
sci-fi fan definitely check it out is
really really worth the time
all right the third one we saw this week
was the perfection yeah it's alright
movie no yeah this was actually a
Netflix movie I believe that it
premiered I mean technically it's not a
20-19 movie because I believe it
premiered at Fantastic Fest in late 2018
but Netflix didn't get it until late May
of 2019
now I had seen that there was like a
huge amount of like buzz about this
movie like when it first like hit
Netflix back in May but I didn't watch
it at the time because it was like other
stuff that I was watching like other
series and stuff and I didn't really get
around to it and I managed to avoid any
spoilers or even like what the movie was
really about which I think enhanced my
enjoyment of it because this is one of
those movies where I think it's better
if you don't really know anything about
it going in yeah kind of but I didn't
really know anything going about it
going in I thought the Bourne the
beginning was kind of boring I'm like
what's this about what did you want to
show where it was going yeah I'm like
you know come on you know I mean it I
get to it but it didn't take long it was
for maybe only 15 minutes yeah so
they're kind of drunken crab yeah that
too yeah the class started thicken as
soon as they were on the bus yeah going
through China yeah and she started
vomiting up all the work you know and
then if worms are on me yeah I was going
like what the hell was happening and
then one thing leads to another and you
find out more and it's weird something
will happen and it's not really well
explained but then it backs up and it
backs up like a damn videotape to show
you something else that it happened yeah
like war that you didn't
recontextualizes like I think that you
say and it does a great way of doing a
flashback because a lot of times when
these sons of [ __ ] do a flashback I'm
like huh well happen I'm too dumb to
follow the flashback plate in Reverse
you're like okay
okay good yeah yeah yeah wrapping tape
so you know that I see that again for
boy right is he trying to get too fancy
yeah they're trying to get some fancy on
me you know I'm too monkeyish you can't
get fancy
who are these people no one younger
exactly like his old man what was going
on he does at the movie theaters showing
us traditional folks aren't really down
with that kind of storytelling
he doesn't know how to lie got [ __ ]
jumping around like he doesn't know how
to pick up like context clues that's not
like that [ __ ] no I like Toby be it a
beginning a middle and end and it kind
of unfolds like us like a tail you know
anyway sorry yeah weird week I know this
is gonna sound like a little bit off the
wall but the structure of this reminded
me a little bit of that of the movie
about the assassin we just saw the other
day it was directed by yeah yeah that's
on the antowain where it would go like a
head and then it'd go away yeah oh and
stuff like that but um yeah this one
only does it a couple of times and I
have to say the cool thing about this
and like I said the only the only thing
I knew about this going in I don't want
a trailer i watch like part of a trailer
but that's about it
was that it was like about two Chellis
whoo and it was like a rivalry and
that's how they set it up because
netflix didn't want you knowing where
this was going
now I think like it was directed by
Richard Shepherd and he's done like a
[ __ ] ton of like movies and TV like he
did the matador he did like a bunch of
episodes of girls and stuff but I was
like the most excited but I looked at
his IMDB page to discover that he had
directed the 1991 movie the linguine
incident and I loved that [ __ ] movie
and I feel like a lot of people haven't
seen it even though [ __ ] David Bowie
and Rosanna Arquette were in it it was
hilarious and what did that one jump
around to um no that was that it was
very very different came across it
jumped around on a count-out tolerated
it was made by a dude I went to
Dominguez elementary school
Quentin Tarantino yeah fiction yeah Pulp
Fiction Pulp Fiction jumped around
alright I gotta find Quentin's [ __ ]
third-grade kitchen I got picture
[ __ ] me and quitting the third great
sin that it's in that is in there
somewhere
yeah not and I didn't like I don't like
his movies mostly yeah but some of the
newer ones that he's done that I saw I
liked it I liked Pulp Fiction
I liked Reservoir Dogs well those were
his old ones yeah you could tell that
those were you know that you could tell
Reservoir Dogs was a play really made it
to a movie if you ask me but but the
Kill Bill stuff is I didn't read was
worth a minute it but that one jumped
around but the way he did it it made it
obvious that it was jumping around yeah
Wow
he did a good job well because you could
tell that things were happening from
like a different person yeah we're never
close and you and yes that was going
things happened is I thought he was
pretty cool but like I said what this
one does
it's like it does it a couple of times
and like I said yes in like apparently
the guy this is actually more structured
like a Korean horror thriller which is
what I would call this is a horror
thriller and in particular he he really
liked the 2016 Korean revenge thriller
the handmaiden and he wanted to make
something like that so that's kind of
where they're going so it has this
structure where it's like it's a
build-up it's a build-up and all this
stuff happens and then it kinda goes in
like a body horror kind of direction and
then you're like what the [ __ ] is going
on and then it like backs up and it's
like this is what happened that and it
recontextualizes everything and then the
second half does that too like it kind
of goes on it goes on and goes on and
you think it's going one way but then it
backs up and goes no this was really
happening behind the scenes and stuff so
it recontextualizes everything again so
like I said I think it's kind of better
if you just kind of like watch it
without like just kind of let it take
you on a journey you know what I mean
it's like some kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happens at this movie I have to say like
I just you know the two actresses in it
were really good it's like I didn't find
this quite as compelling as I am mother
the sci-fi movie that which was probably
my favorite one of all the three that we
watched this week yeah but I liked that
this one was like so twisty and I
had no [ __ ] idea it comes out of
nowhere it's a pretty good movie when it
started off I just thought man what kind
of chick flick is this there were a lot
of chicks in it you know good-looking
ones too
but it it has a lot of female appeal but
guy a guy can appreciate it yes if you
know it and you see where it's going
right you can see where it's going even
though you know they're victimized and
dudes I mean the dudes aren't guilty
though well they deserve yeah yeah
they're good also Steven Weber isn't
it's just it's a rigid French flick
almost kind of like I Spit on Your Grave
I was gonna say it's it's like I would
say it kind of goes in a rape revenge
rate was very bland which now that you
mention it I had forgotten all about
this and we we watched this before we
started like doing Netflix movies on our
show and this probably came out in a few
years ago anyway 2016 2017 there is a
great movie I don't think it's on
Netflix I think it's on shudder but it's
just called revenge and it's also kind
of it's like a modern rape revenge movie
I think it's twenty thousand twenty
sixteen or something I would also
recommend that one that was like really
really good um so you know if you like
that genre you know that sub-genre and
you haven't seen it I heard that cold
hell was also good too but I haven't
seen that one yet I think that's also
one shudder but yeah if you like that
kind of flick like I said and this
definitely has some grody like body
horror elements um has some good
gourd-like though not until the end and
some kind of fucked-up [ __ ] happens like
I said but I you know I kind of dug it
like I said it wasn't my favorite movie
of the week that would have been I am I
was a good movie but it was a good movie
and like I said it kind of it took me on
a journey but you had to be willing to
take that journey with because like I
said it was structured very much like a
Korean like crime thriller type of thing
or like a horror thriller that you know
it kind of jumped around and you know
just had that kind of thing yeah so as a
man you're gonna be good you're gonna be
going the first ten minutes like what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] going well okay
the girls in this mood but they can show
you some naked oh like girls and show
you some naked lesbian action without
can't
whoa wait a minute what and then you go
oh [ __ ] the workers it was worth
watching it wasn't as good as the the
robot movie yeah my mother wasn't that
good yeah and I still think I like edge
the edge of the world better remember
the world rim oh yeah remember the world
rim in the world man in the world
that's the porno first yeah yeah the
world I don't want to rim the whole
world just think who's in the whole
world
that's right you unhinge it I can I can
think of like at least 10 people right
now that I would not even want to get
that close to much less get close to
there but damn man us a video review
sorry
talking about I guess I brought it up
yeah you did like I said it's like
you're taking that [ __ ] okay
is that like he goes off in that kind of
direction and a long with me and then he
like yells at thing about it like I did
it and I'm like what man I'm just taking
your [ __ ] out of it you started it but
yeah so this is on Netflix right now I'm
sure it'll be on there for quite a while
because like I said there was a lot of
buzz about it on social media and it's
only been on there since the end of May
so go check it out if you like that kind
of thing
[Music]